This hah.
Oh!
[LAUGH]
>> Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and this is Bob here.
We're playing Skate 3 because it's
been highly demanded
and we've been trying to, what are you
doing?
>> I don't know.
>> You okay there?
>> Just taking a nap.
Just leave me alone.
>> We've never played before and we
plugged in at about,
[CROSSTALK].
>> Oh, no.
[LAUGH]
>> So we're going to take turns playing
it, because Bob's flight leaves in
about an hour, so we wanted to record
something else and this is it.
So.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> How do I jump again?
>> You have to like push.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Whoa, that was magic!
>> Oh yeah!
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> What, what are you doing?
>> I don't know, I'm just pressing
buttons.
I don't know how to play this.
Okay alright.
>> You lost, you lost your skateboard.
[LAUGH]
>> Shut up.
>> Oh that's right you have the force.
>> That was the first, God damn it.
How do I get back on it.
I never figured that out.
>> Triangle.
>> Oh, okay, okay.
>> Oh my God jump over the side.
God.
[LAUGH]
>> Oh, God damn it.
[LAUGH].
Oh my God
>> [LAUGH].
Quarry, quarry sound good ?
[LAUGH]
>> I, I don't need this anymore.
>> Oh God.
Ooh!
[LAUGH]
Oh God!
No, okay.
Eh.
Oh my God no!
[LAUGH]
>> Jump, fucking skateboard!
I don't need a skateboard for this!
>> It's not.
Shit.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Shit.
>> There we go.
Shit.
[LAUGH]
God damn it.
Shit.
>> Can you run to the top of this ramp?
>> I don't know.
[LAUGH]
What did I do?
Okay.
[LAUGH]
>> There you go.
Yeah that's how you play console games.
[LAUGH]
You need at least five fingers.
>> Yeah.
Oh, no.
No, no!
[LAUGH]
>> Shit.
All right, you take over, I'm not doing
well.
[LAUGH]
>> Mm.
>> Blistering fast, I like that.
[LAUGH]
>> That's what we were looking for.
>> [NOISE]
Blistering speed.
Perfect.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Speed.
Speed.
>> Camera getting less clear
>> [LAUGH]
Oh come on.
Oh, saved it.
Come back here.
Some speed right there, that's some speed
man.
[NOISE]
>> [LAUGH]
That's a big, not much speed.
>> You gotta slow down.
[LAUGH]
>> What.
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH]
>> Come back here you big, come back
here, I'm going to get you, I'm going to
get you.
[LAUGH]
Woop!
No, no, no!
Get off the thing!
God!
Oh no!
This is the big ramp I just jumped down!
>> Okay, go down that ramp if you feel so
inclined.
Get it?
>> Oh God!
No!
[LAUGH]
God dang it!
Shoot and whoop, and whoop.
And, oh!
>> [LAUGH]
>> Oh!
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] God dangit!
>> [LAUGH]
>> Is that doing your finger wagging?
>> Either that or I'm doing this.
>> [LAUGH]
God.
All right.
>> Huh.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
Aw!
No, no!
Oh yeah, see, I got it, I got it.
[NOISE]
[LAUGH]
Oh god.
Oh my god.
[LAUGH]
Oh
Oh no.
[LAUGH]
[SOUND]
What the hell?
[LAUGH]
>> Grr, gimme my skateboard!
Save me, skateboard.
[LAUGH]
>> Shut up.
I can do this.
>> Speed, speed, speed.
>> I got it, hang on.
[SOUND] What?
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> And
[SOUND]
and
[SOUND]!
Aah!
>> [LAUGH]
Oh, I broke my spine.
[LAUGH]
Alright.
Perfect.
[MUSIC]
[LAUGH]
Give me a bit.
>> Oh my God.
>> I want the viewers out there to
experience.
>> Oh no, God it's still happening.